all right as we continue tonight on
hannity uh with our big breaking news
joining us is the author of the massive
10 weeks in a row number one new york
times bestseller american marxism i call
him the great one mark levin of course
he hosts life liberty live in here on
the fox news channel number one
in his time slot
and
mark i have a longer
introduction question
everybody knows we're friends
everybody i think knows that we have a
shared passion for this country a love
of this country
a love for the rule of law our laws are
based on that document you spent a good
part of your life studying called the
constitution
uh we believe in due process we believe
in equal justice we don't we believe in
the presumption of innocence equal
application of laws equal justice under
the law
and
you and i have something else in common
we were right on ferguson missouri we're
right about the cambridge police we were
right on duke lacrosse
right on uva right in baltimore maryland
and all these same idiots politicians
like joe biden
hollywood stars these idiot liberal
commentators on cable news channels
they're wrong every single time mark
they rush to judgment every time they
deny due process every time
and i want your thoughts on
on when they do that the they create an
atmosphere and an expectation of a
result
that when the evidence comes in is never
going to happen i believe that's likely
to happen again your thoughts sir
i think as a people
we have to conclude that the media in
america today are racist
they are corrupt and they are evil
they have no intention of reporting the
news they have no intention of seeking
to be objective or impartial we have
seen that for years now
and the american people hold the media
in this country in contempt the problem
is
you have these massive corporations like
att owned cnn comcast owns msnbc you can
go down the list
and they basically immunize these phony
news slash propaganda outfits so it
doesn't matter if they get ratings it
doesn't matter what they say when you
watch the kind of people msnbc has as
hosts
joy reid a flat out bigot and you watch
the other people they bring on
this michael eric dyson and others
who just are predictable in the
outrageous and poisonous things that
they say
i believe the media in this country is
helping to fuel riots it's helping to
fuel
divisiveness it's helping to fuel hate
in this country
and you can see we're at each other's
throats where that wasn't really the
case before and they work with the
democrat party they promote aoc and
presley and talib and omar
these are anti-semites these are bigots
you can see joe biden does their bidding
with his executive orders it's just
appalling the use of jim crow when a
republican legislature is actually
putting in statutes that are more
liberal than what they have in democrat
delaware where joe biden spent his
entire life
and more and more this is going on they
are mainstreaming bigotry when you see
the way they treated the lieutenant
governor
wins some sears the things they said
about her
uh if it was a white person talking
about a black person they would be
banned and they should be banned the
things that are said on the house floor
about white people and jews and so forth
people should be expelled
this prosecutor in this case against
kyle rittenhouse needs to have ethics
complaints filed against him with the
supreme court of wisconsin i went back
and i looked at these charges these
charges are not acceptable they're thin
to bring charges within 36 to 48 hours
of a case like this before you actually
have an opportunity representing the
state to get all the facts to get all
the information to make a determination
of what you should do your job
as a prosecutor is to get to the truth
you represent the government you
represent the state
and so what's happening here is these
prosecutors that soros puts in or
they're just weak on their own they
respond to the mob
and right now we have mob justice
depending on who you are and what the
situation is even tonight in kenosha the
police are preparing for possible
violence if the if the jury doesn't rule
the way the mob wants them the rule the
way the media want them the rule the way
hakeem jeffries and the democrats want
them to rule the way lebron james and
other democrats want them to rule
this kid went on the stand
and he defended himself he defended his
freedom
and he was superb
if you're guilty as hell trust me you're
not going to go on that stand and he
withstood the lies and the attacks by
the prosecutor trying to trick him he's
18 years old he was absolutely
outstanding he defended himself if this
kid hadn't shot rosenbaum he'd be dead
if this kid hadn't shot huber he'd be
dead if this kid hadn't shot gross
krentz he'd be dead
now we keep hearing about this kid oh he
had 30 rounds in his rifle what should
he have had 10 oh we crossed state lines
to go to kenosha first of all he didn't
and so what if he did his father lived
there
why is he the one that's on defense
why is he the one that has to explain
himself to the media they don't tell us
about rosenbaum rosenbaum grabbed the
barrel of the rifle now who is this guy
he's prohibited from possessing or was
firearms he had sex with a minor
gruesome grotesque sex with a minor he's
a bail jumper two domestic abuse charges
that's rosenbaum you haven't heard about
rosenbaum how about huber hits him in
the head
chases him with a skateboard that's like
a bat then hits him in the neck with a
skateboard who was he well among other
things he had he was a domestic abuse
repeater well shouldn't people know that
who's gross cranch just this poor guy
who was walking around carrying a pistol
why did he carry a pistol why did he aim
it at this kid's head
he wasn't provoked he chose to do that
himself and as he said on the stand
that's when he got shot
so my view is this is disgusting and
what about the governor wisconsin the
president of the united states at the
time donald trump called the governor
when kenosha was burning and said i will
agree to send in more national guardsmen
because you can't defend the city he
said no why isn't he responsible for
anything the writer is responsible for
anything and this damn disgusting media
that tries to turn american against
american it is outrageous joe
scarborough if he had been black he
wouldn't be treated this way while he
was white
the three men who attacked him were
white two of whom died from shots were
white the one that was shot in the arm
was white what is joe scarbar the
whitest guy on tv even talking about
what in the hell does this have to do
with race the issue is whether this
kyle rittenhouse this young man had a
right to defend himself and the answer
is
absolutely yes it's not that the
prosecution was incompetent they were
politically motivated they did not have
a case that's why they resorted to
violating the constitution and the
judge's orders and that's why this
prosecutor's ass should be in for in
front of an ethics committee in the
supreme court of wisconsin
that's it
a great one mark levin life liberty and
levin sunday nights 8 pm right here on
fox thank you mark all right now joe
biden today had one of his most
disturbing troubling moments to date
saying this when telling his stories
told him before about the late great
baseball player
satchel page during his remarks at
arlington national cemetery take a look
you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson his name was satchel page
imagine if donald trump said that
where's the outrage from the media mob
what would the reaction be if it was
donald trump why does the media mob why
does the left always give joe biden a
pass on not only every issue but
especially on the issue of race the same
joe biden that praised and worked with
the former klansmen robert kkk byrd to
stop integration of schools and school
business he didn't want his words public
schools to become racial jungles that's
what joe biden said
imagine if that was donald trump and for
years this is how joe biden has talked
about race
imagine again if it was donald trump
take a look
madam president we have predators on our
streets the largest growth in population
is indian americans moving from india
you cannot go to a 7-11
or a dunkin donuts unless you have a
slight indian accent
what kind of a chance would a
northeastern liberal like joe biden
stand
in the south better than anybody else
and you don't know my state my state was
a slave state you got the first
sort of
mainstream african american
who was articulate and bright and
we got more questions
you got more questions but i tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or trump and you ain't
black
joe biden his own words the words the
media wants to pretend don't exist here
with reaction leo 2.0 terrell along with
outkick founder co-host of the clay
travis buck sexton show clay travis leo
we start with you tonight um
what was your reaction first of all to
what he said
today he's told this story before
and nobody seems to bat an eyelash and
what would the reaction be if it was
donald trump
oh first of all let me answer your
question
my reaction to what he said today the
word negro that's a that's the generic
version of the n word no one
uses that word to describe great black
americans that word is banned by the
federal government during the obama
administration it is offensive you don't
use that term in any way shape or form
to show your appreciation towards black
americans i was offended by but i'm not
surprised it's the single reason why i
left the democratic party when that last
clip you played when you said you know
if you vote for trump you ain't black
how dare joe biden makes those
accusations but he's the democratic
racist that's why he gets a pass people
need to understand that if trump said
those words it's 24 7
racist comments by cnn and msnbc the
democrats will accept embrace their own
races but if you are a republican if he
would have used that word any other
person they would be crucified by the
left-wing media the democratic party is
racist and let me talk in joe biden's
manner joe
you're a racist he likes to whisper so
i'll whisper to him you're racist
all right that was good you caught me
off guard there leo uh clay let me go to
you in this sense i talk about this
every election season because every two
years every four years democrats have
one playbook republicans are racist
sexist misogynist homophobic xenophobic
now transphobic islamophobic let's see
what else oh they want dirty air and
water and they want to throw grandma and
grandpa over the cliff
that's their playbook
but
you know look how quickly they wanted to
label kyle rittenhouse a white
supremacist compare that to joe biden's
language this week and compare it to
his partnership with the former klansmen
not wanting schools to become racial
jungles that would be a death sentence
for any republican candidate for any
office
you're 100 right john and this is where
narrative trump's fact i think we can
and analyze this with what's going on
with kyle rittenhouse the narrative was
this was a white supremacist this was a
racist this was a deviant school shooter
that's what they called him at cnn msnbc
everywhere and a lot of people as
they've watched this trial has said wait
a minute i don't know necessarily that
the narrative is overlapping in any way
with what the actual fact pattern is and
leo's 100 right about this if donald
trump had said
what joe biden said today it would be
the number one story on cnn it would be
the number one story on msnbc and it's
unfortunate we're two weeks away from
thanksgiving and every single day and
every single week and every single month
joe biden becomes more of what everybody
who sits at the thanksgiving table has
experienced a doddering old incompetent
person who unfortunately cannot complete
their thoughts usually whether it's your
old aunt your old uncle your grandma
your grandpa the positive is there you
love them because they're in your family
but they aren't trying to run the
country sean in leo that's what joe
biden is every single day he gets worked
he's the worst person at thanksgiving to
run the country at all of our family
tables except he's running the whole
country it's a mess i don't think i'd
trust him to stir the gravy to be honest
on thanksgiving
amen certainly wouldn't wouldn't trust
him to cook
no that's true
real quick at 30 seconds i want your
take
uh you've been a lawyer all your career
civil rights lawyer leo um i'm watching
this case again they say oh joe biden
accused him of being a white supremacist
putting that aside i do not see
how a jury with all the evidence that
we've been discussing tonight gets to a
guilty verdict to you
i do not i've been on your radio show
and i want to thank that judge who is
the the arbitrator the final
mediator of justice he's handing out
justice and he's really the prosecutor
the riot act this
kyle rittenhouse has a solid affirmative
defense for self-defense not even close
still haven't gotten my hat and i still
haven't got my uh let's go brandon
t-shirts
and i don't know you're a bunch of fans
by the way i want my hat and i want my
let's go brandon t-shirt so i can wear
it out and get yelled at
i'm bringing it to you in person sean at
the patriot at the patriot awards all
right thank you both when we come back
after spending two days with texas
public safety officers our very own
sarah carter does an investigative
report an exclusive report about cartel
murders now happening right here inside
the usa she joins us next
this is the dimension of imagination
[Music]
[Music]
it's a mixed up world and the way we
work looks a little different but
whether you embrace the new normal or
just want to get back to the routines
that feel right x chair continues to be
at the forefront of change which is why
we've launched the all-new x-chair with
lmx lmx combines gentle body temperature
regulation with stress melting massage
to increase your comfort working from
home or at the office feel more
refreshed in seconds with dual fans that
actively deliver a cooling airflow or
you can wrap your back in the soothing
warmth of heat therapy and access four
combinations of massage for deep relief
from tension our patented dynamic
variable lumbar support and sciflow
infinite recline technology remain
unchanged order a next chair with lmx
today use code tv and get fifty dollars
off plus a free foot rest hey change
happen and we've made it a good thing
with all new lmx from xg now the future
feels better than ever before order x
chair with lmx today use code tv and get
50 off plus a free footrest from roof to
foundation the damage to your home can
be devastating from clogged gutters
leaking roofs and flooded basements
protect your entire home with leaffilter
leaffilter's micromesh screen is
guaranteed to filter out everything
except for water it's protected my home
i love it call 833 leaffilter or go to
getleaffilter.com for your free gutter
inspection and estimate
call or log on today and save 15 percent